e você
o Olá boa tarde eu sou o Miguel tenho 50
anos sou pai de três filhos casado com a
Sandra vivem ou Nova de Gaia Sou natural
de Angola Luanda os meus pais eram
Imigrantes aqui tem um conselho que é
meda e também eles foram a descoberta EA
ultrapassar as fronteiras do empresário
e vários ramos de atividade responsável
em associações empresariais e dá uma
forma a minha vida foi sempre um desafio
e um esforço Grande pela pela pela
ultrapassar as dificuldades que me foram
encontrar é engraçado passarmos um
bocado esta mensagem rápida mas a minha
vida muda muito ao final há cerca de 20
anos com dois eventos foi uma
Infelizmente o falecimento do meu pai
precoce e outro problema de saúde plano
de saúde que tinha a ver com o meu
sedentarismo em que tive que alterar é o
meu a minha rotina tive que mudar a mim
O Pioneiro stand no dia a dia e passar a
exercitar atividades regulares de
físicas fiz BTT fisgas fácil aliás BTT
facilidade viciado que eu fiz atletismo
e fui dá uma forma de grandes desafios
nacionais e internacionais Há dois anos
foi desafiado por um amigo deste destas
aventuras Eu sou amigo o Miguel
Rodrigues teve uma ideia que nos
pareceram bastante interessada foi da
forma sobre a listinha dos anos de
circum-navegação de Fernão Magalhães
também ele serosa Vila Real Imaginem o
marinheiro de sabrosa e dá uma forma
aqui foi necessário criar uma estrutura
com alguma dimensão com alguma qualidade
desde logo a chancela da Câmara
Municipal de Vila Nova de Gaia pela
Doutora Paula Carvalhal Bel Ribeiro
pelouro da cultura onde com
e se montar uma ideia que passava
essencialmente por levar uma missiva da
cidade magalhanica que a Vila Nova de
Gaia a três duas outras autarquias no
Chile e na Argentina isto implicava
necessariamente bastante bastante
cuidado para que as coisas funcionassem
ainda foi no outro tempo antes da
pandemia tentou em janeiro 2020 outro
tempo e conseguimos da forma criar toda
este telan através de um KickOff feito
aqui em do corpo de Cristo e aqui bem
perto onde fomos se recebemos da
autarquia duas missivas para levar a
ponta Arenas de direção Juliano na
Argentina Além disso vamos amigos cartas
florais do município e aterramos em em
Santiago do Chile com temperaturas
diferentes com Burke
é completamente de tintas a melhor idade
com isso também foi importante tivemos
que montar todo mundo todo uma
estratégia de fazer com que as notas
ficar sem condições e fossem viáveis
para para continuar a nossa gente fomos
atravessarmos um pouco para o país
tivemos desde logo vários desafios de
seja Logístico esteja das diferentes
fronteiras comos atravessando é eu
gostava de realçar que era quero facto
de ter sobrado algumas 49 anos em em em
São Martinho da lan desse onde tivemos
uma noite tremenda de condução cerca de
300 400 km em baixo de chuva onde eu
nunca tinha visto um amigo meu fazer
tanto a caçada de coelho e evitar tantas
vacas no meio das estradas não
iluminadas foi um verdadeiro desafio
chegarmos a aí ao Calafate depois de
a 200 e poucos quilómetros de rípio nós
temos rípio é uma espécie de brita em
que temos conduzir com moto extremamente
pesadas de fazer aquele percurso todo
sem que houvesse qualquer impedimento de
seguir a nossa missão chegar a chegarem
ao Calafate onde quem não conheço a
merece ser visitado estão Glaciar el
Perito Moreno em que autenticamente o
rio parou congelou com muralhas de cerca
de 70 kg 70 metros de altura onde a
presença o proximidade nós podemos
sentir a tensão do gelo que parte que
faz um trovão constante e e foi foi
facto impressionante de ver aqueles
antes e viver todo aquele trajeto em
direção ao sul de fomos a nossa primeira
entrega em Punta Arenas em onde fomos
recebidos por um ao Cade o Cláudio e o
romanes
a origem Croata que nos recebeu de forma
excepcional onde entregamos a missiva
para as celebrações dos 500 anos de
deste deste das 500 anos a segunda
vocação do Frango líderes que ainda não
se livraram espero que se vende sobrado
próximo a mente e onde dá uma forma
tínhamos ali no Estreito de Magalhães
onde estivemos onde o local onde o
flambo milhões Depois de várias
tentativas de erro conseguiu atravessar
o Atlântico para o Pacífico onde o clima
é completamente já glaciares com a terem
uma ideia média do vento rondou os 20 Km
e pode atingir rajadas ou mais de 200 km
onde conduzir motas pode ser um
verdadeiro ato de acrobacia fazer curvas
à direita inclinado à esquerda paramos
as motas motas tombavam tanto eram um
verdadeiro desafio tivemos um uma
situação numa travessia de ferry
o que eu tive uma hora Parecia um
astronauta com capacete todo equipado
resguardado ao pé de um um um pneu de um
caminhão para não estar a sofrer com
vento que o vento levava e paro é
começarmos depois de subida já do lado
Atlântico e virmos a ter partes e
Juliano para ter Julian era um Porto que
foram milhares e identificou Como Um
porto de segurança onde estava com os
seus navios e onde fazia várias várias
incursões até conseguir descobrir o
Estreito de Magalhães e testar para o
Pacífico Este foi mais uma uma um
momento alto onde fomos excelentemente
recebidos pela pela pela pelo pelos
Alcatel Alcaide de Porto São Julião onde
entregamos esta missiva e a carta foral
que a Câmara Municipal de Gaia nos nos
delegou e a partir dali claramente
respiramos vivemos cumprido a nossa
missão tínhamos feito o resto
a lidar com situações diferentes tudo em
autonomia não tivemos em mente algum
necessidade de ultrapassar esta situação
e e conseguimos pois ou com algum prazer
começar a rezar e tivemos ainda a
oportunidade de estar em Mar del Plata
com o amigo Pablo salomonense que é um
de origem de origem italiana que nos
convidou a comer corrente misto grelhado
argentino novinho e regressar Buenos
Aires Buenos Aires é uma cidade
fantástica com quem caminha em Buenos
Aires sente que está ou ainda teria ou
em Paris onde tem uma avenida com 140
metros de largura onde a dimensão é é
fogosa e regressar a passar a casa são e
salvo estar com os nossos esperar que
haja essa possibilidade de fazermos a
celebração dos 500 500 anos do da sua
navegação do framboesas aqui em Vila
Nova de Gaia e
E acima de tudo eu gostava muito dos
enfatizar que isto teve Pontos
importantes porque não é radical fazer
as coisas radical não tem plano b fazer
Aventura tem plano b devemos assegurar
todas as funções foi que nós fizemos um
envolver várias entidades desde logo a
torrestir a parte da da Baviera nos
jogou desde logo também a própria
relação relação que tivemos com o porto
canal que acompanhou todas as etapas da
vida económica foi importante Porque é
importante além do que fazemos passar
essa mensagem por último estava muito de
vos dar um bocado esta ideia já que
falamos em em outra passar a fronteira
sem em chegar ao infinito e e como eu
fiz ir até o fim do mundo gostava muito
de pássaros na mensagem que foi porque
nos foi passada numa no evento que
fizemos numa espécie de caminho de
Santiago se chama havia frente de gênero
de liga
o apevia e fizemos a cerca de dez anos
por BTT e tivemos a pequena cerimônia
junto ao túmulo de Santa Paula
Frassinetti fundadora das dorotéias aqui
em Portugal e que este este sacerdote
disso nos algo para mim nunca mais me
esquecer se queres ir rápido vai sozinha
se queres e longe vai acompanhado e
portanto claramente a mensagem que eu
gostava de transmitir aqui seja para o
Infinito seja para para para o fim do
mundo seja para onde for temos que ir
acompanhados e isso é muito importante e
pensar bem processo ter cuidado com tudo
o que fazemos e Usufruir e passarmos a
mensagem é a mensagem que tenho a
mensagem muito agradável e espero ainda
ter mais desafios pelos dois passar no
futuro obrigado a